hey this is presh talwalkar
evaluate the following sum
sine squared of one degree plus sine
squared of two degrees plus sine squared
of three degrees and so on until the
final two terms
sine squared of 89 degrees plus sine
squared of 90 degrees
this problem appeared in the 2021 oxford
maths admissions test
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall
cosine x is equal to sine of 90 degrees
minus x
squaring both sides of the equation
gives cosine squared x is equal to sine
squared of 90 degrees minus x
next recall sine squared x plus cosine
squared x is equal to 1. substituting
for cosine squared x gives sine squared
x
plus sine squared of ninety degrees
minus x is equal to one
we will use this identity to solve the
problem
we can pair sine squared 1 degree with
sine squared of 89 degrees
this sum is equal to 1.
we can then pair sine squared of 2
degrees plus sine squared of 88 degrees
that sum is also equal to 1.
this pattern continues
until we get to sine squared of 44
degrees plus sine squared of 46 degrees
and that sum will also be equal to 1.
these 44 pairs will have a total sum
equal to 44.
so we've evaluated
88 terms
which will be equal to 44.
but this entire sum has 90 terms
so there are two terms we still need to
add
one is sine squared of 45 degrees and
the other is sine squared of 90 degrees
sine of 45 degrees is equal to 1 divided
by the square root of 2
and sine of 90 degrees is equal to 1.
we then square both of these terms and
add to get 44 plus 1 half plus 1
and that's equal to 45.5
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]